demi lovato is now identifying as
she previously identified as pansexual
she's now changing that to identify as
non-binary
i don't know exactly what the difference
is between those things
but i know that the effect of this
latter one is that she now identifies as
multiple people
she wants her preferred pronouns to be
they
and them and she announced this in
a pretty trippy video living in the
fourth dimension means existing
consciously and both time and space
hold on pause it right there already you
see we have a little problem about the
agreement and disagreement on reality
she says living in the fourth dimension
means living consciously in time and
space
that's called living in the third
dimension right i don't i'm not a
physicist but
i'm living in the in 3d right now i can
i see i've got space i see understand
volume and things like that
and i'm i'm living in time i
don't i know sometimes people call time
the fourth dimension i don't know it
seems a little
hippy dippy to me so already i think the
inter-dimensional
aspect of this video has me primed and
ready to assume she's not going to be
totally coherent she goes on but for me
it means having conversations that
transcend the typical discourse
i want to take this moment to share
something very personal with you over
the past year and a half i've been doing
some healing and self-reflective work
and through this work i've had the
revelation that i identify as non-binary
with that said i'll officially be
changing my pronouns to they them
pause pause again you can't do that
you can't that but it's my personal
choice i've had this revelation where
did you get this revelation from
who gave you this revelation that you
are multiple people the only
a book where i have seen a sort of
revelation that an individual person is
multiple people
is this very old book sometimes called
the good book uh in which
uh one person shrieks out we are legion
we are you know and it's but it's that
would be demons demons would be doing
because you
a one person can't be multiple people
and the smiling and i've done some
healing work
and some self-reflection you hear this a
lot from the they're always healing
because of some trauma that has been
done to them and i actually i don't even
mean to discount this yeah
people go through dramas that is life
that is part of life
but it's always we're healing and
because i'm healing you can't question
me
because i'm trying to recover from this
trauma you can't ever
question my delusions so i
am multiple people what does that mean
what does it mean to be they and them
i feel that this best represents the
fluidity i feel in my gender expression
and allows me to feel most authentic and
true to the person i both know i
am and still am discovering in this
first episode i'm excited to share with
you
what this means to me and what it may
look like for other people
i want to make it clear that i'm still
learning and coming into myself
and i don't claim to be an expert or a
spokesperson
i know this might be a new conversation
for many so i'm inviting my friend alok
someone i trust to spend time on this
platform alok is an author performer and
an important voice within the non-binary
community and beyond
their work to create visibility equality
and understanding
has inspired me on my healing journey
we'll discuss identity at large
but also take the time to personally
reflect on how i came into my truth
so that we like many others are able to
live our lives authentically
in just a minute i'm going to share
space with alok and dive deeper into
this conversation
if you told me michael
hundred thousand dollars on the line you
get one guess
what is the name of this lady's friend
i would probably guess alok that's i
wouldn't have guessed john
or bert you know i think alok sounds
about right
this video matters not because of
anything involving demi lovato i mean
the headline here is
entertainer begs for attention wow
not exactly a man bites dog story is it
so of course you know
entertainers do this all the time and
they just try to get more attention
particularly as their careers are
sort of on the on the way back down so
not not surprised here but the way that
demi lovato is doing this is by
just parroting it's like a parody of
leftist jargon she's just fitting all
the leftist slogans my truth and
self-discovery and healing and this
journey
into all into one sentence and it's you
know it's not going to be coherent
really from the beginning of it with the
fourth dimension stuff but even in in
this little bit
she says we're going to talk about the
person
that i know i am and am still becoming
if you're still becoming that then you
don't know that you are that person you
can't
you can't both be this firm set person
and this other thing that you don't know
what it is that you're headed to
that just that alone is not possible but
it's actually multiple people right it's
they
and it's them and
that sort of thing does not jibe with
any semblance of society it's this the
radical subjectivism of the phrase
my truth is enough just that alone is
enough
to destroy society i'm not being
hyperbolic here folks
i i don't mean to say that the bizarre
musings of some entertainer
are threatening to destabilize society
she's representing a very
popular ideology right now and if we
cannot agree that there is truth in tim
ryan's words if we can't agree on
reality
then we can't get along in society and
what she's saying is not even i disagree
with conservatives on reality she's
saying i don't believe there is reality
i'm saying it's my truth
and i'm becoming this radically
subjective thing i know look i know i
look like a woman and everything and i
talk like a woman and i
obviously am a woman but i've had a
revelation that i know that my true self
who i
am not even that person yet but i know
that i am that person
is multiple people
well there goes society there it's over
hey there are you living in the demi
lovato fantasyland you probably are if
you have not run that bell if you have
not subscribed
because you all you're doing is swimming
in this morass of delusion and fantasy
but what you got to do is live in this
reality based community okay ring that
bell
like subscribe i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you